warum herzlich kommst du mal wieder
leute sehr schlau und sehr vorbildlich
von euch dass ihr heute wieder
eingeschaltet habe ich bin heute durch
youtube durchgespielt habe so ein
bisschen wir die zeit vertrieben hat mir
gedacht okay was kann ich dafür ein
video machen bin da auf ein video
gestoßen das mich sehr schockiert hat ja
ich glaube man kann schockieren sagen
und es ist leute für alle die das wort
rtl2 nicht mehr hören können kein krass
schule und keine hilfe video sondern ein
bisschen interessant das video aber ein
sehr spannendes video jetzt immer sich
hat gesehen dass wir jetzt ein bisschen
mehr hoch lade einfach weil 40 euro
das heißt wir ein bisschen mehr videos
bisschen mehr platz und neue sachen
ausprobieren und das machen wir heute
leute und auch nennt der pinsel mal ganz
abgesehen von dem fakt dass es krass ist
dass er personen tatsächlich solche
haare hat so wer wacht eines morgens auf
und denkt sich ich weiß es ich weiß was
man die ganze gefehlt hat ich habe
einfach nicht genug pinsel aus gesehen
[Gelächter]
also nicht nur der pinsel ich muss
zurück wie heute es ist nicht nur der
pinsel
es ist auch natürlich das pferd hier zu
erkennen die neue harmonie nachdem der
pinsel dann natürlich bisschen aus der
mode gekommen ist wenn man ist ja klar
wie es mit jener frisur ist er sagt
macht euch dass das gefährt aussieht
das ist okay dass keine frisur kommentar
sagt einer der frisur für die ihr
bekanntes ist der topf fällt dazu zeigen
sie dieses bild leute nochmal ist ich
sage es noch mal für euch da in keine
ahnung england wahrscheinlich
es ist der pinsel
ok und das ist ein guter pinsel es ist
kein pinsel würde man sich schämen muss
es ist ein wirklich schöner pinsel mit
dem man wenn man jetzt den menschen
einfach nehmen würde und den riesigen
wasser mal verpassten punkten würde man
könnte richtig geil damit mein okay
deswegen geht es nicht so verbreitet
wurde toll ist immer vor so einem club
rhein so geht feier mit allen leuten
2008 euch dürfen noch nicht so einen
diskurs reingeht aber egal egal
darunter war und dann schickt eure
freundin da oder mit einem freund auf
einmal kommt der pinsel in die runde
rein oder in den club rhein gebaut wird
dir und macht euer gehört was würdet ihr
machen
der nächste das wasser schon von dem
pinsel jetzt kommt irgendein asiatin
jetzt hier ins bild und ich weiß nicht
was hat sich gerade eben bei diesem bild
was ich da gesehen hat nicht so gut
angefühlt wie kommentare meinen dort
warten schon so bis mal früh geöffnet
wird also was lässt sein das heißt so
europas könnte dich wirklich erschrecken
was wir dir gleich zeigen aber okay
leute augen zu
das ist wirklich sagen hat sich dieses
video hier angemacht habe mir ausgesucht
habe hatte ich eigentlich schon noch
bock heute abend vielleicht noch normal
schlafen ins bett geht es können kein
träumer zu haben 55
aber gerade in eine richtung die
bisschen davon weg geht lange ist es ist
also längst wimpern war okay schön ja
ich verstehe so die neigung die man am
anfang vielleicht hat flex vlexgroup ist
voll die lang wird man so ich kann mir
die lang wachsen lassen
aber meine geliebte georgina das muss
kannst heißt noch lange nicht dass du es
muss ja catch me sing my latest
klassische situation warnschild
nachmittags im wohnzimmer ein fachmann
zieht ein bisschen an den fünf meter
langen wimpern megawatt an alter stätte
team ab
darüber macht china korea korean von
ihnen also wirklich war okay du kannst
dir wimpern wachsen lassen so ok du
siehst mit dieser schminke sowieso schon
aus wie ein vogel und aber ich finde
sich aus dem vogel und dann entscheidet
sich dazu noch dass sie keine ahnung
sich sowieso ein arzt von atan
gewinntrends teilen lässt ja wow du hast
ahnen es dann deinen augen
gg
european fashion award
okay es geht direkt weiter mühldorf die
feature geht direkt weiter ich dachte
das video wurde vielleicht bist du
andere richtung gehen auch die sorge was
zu lachen erzählt einfach auf irgend so
ein podest aber so auf irgendein
erhöhten platz und kann also schwingt
sein bart aber wieso einlassungen im
moment mit flex du bist ja deswegen auch
okay gesagt leute wie ich gerade gesagt
habe wird flex also ich glaube dieses
videos einfach eine anreihung von
novoflex insofern die längsten wimpern
über ich hab den längst bad was wird als
nächstes kommen wahrscheinlich werden
wir dieses video auf die längsten
fingernägel der welt sehen kein mensch
wollte sie eigentlich sehen aber wieder
was dazugelernt haben was sich irgend
kanadier dazu entschieden sich
zweieinhalb meter an bad stehen zu
lassen
ok ich will das mal für euch also es
geht in die richtung irgendwie ende des
19 jahrhunderts geworden also 1800
irgendwas und 90 x ich habe scheinbar so
wie das jetzt gerade aussieht den
weltrekord für den längsten dauerhaften
schluckauf
er hebt whitney thekenteam die hacker
paulo cent also schon wieder muss man
sagen wirklich wirklich jeder flex aber
eines muss man sagen schau dran ihn so
dass er sich ab hat die chance gegeben
waren also is no freund und no diese
ganze sache zu ende denken aber der wahl
vorhat ganzes leben lang schlug auf den
ganzen tag die ganze nacht gehört könnte
aber richtig schlafen vielleicht nicht
weil ja
perfekt also als er 96 jahre alt wurde
er hat der schluckauf aufgehört das ist
sehr spannend da hat sich ja die ganze
sache doch noch gelohnt am ende ein plus
von 22 bis 96 also nur 74 jahre lang
durchgehend am schluckauf aufschwung
kanadier in california
september ist der store in der ecke bonk
ist tom bruder fangen wir gar nicht erst
mit sowas allen okay also ohne wird
sollte jeder von euch der schon mal eine
freundin hat mit jemanden geküsst hat
kann sich vorstellen welche paranoia hat
sogar vor gibt ihr seid wieder mein klub
die seite relativ auf dem club in
meinsdorf seite so auf dem club keine
ahnung er sagt auf jeden fall wieder
machen und dann treffen so jemanden für
den pool die mädels definierung die
jungs treffen denkt sich so alt garge
bis mit der person die person mag ich
auch dann fällt er um zu machen
packt die einfach oder eher so ein
zwanzig zentimeter apparat aus was los
so weit so sind wir auch einen punkt
angelangt wo es einfach nicht mehr nur
darum geht dass leute irgendwie eine
krasse körperliche veränderung haben
oder irgendwie irgendwas an dem körper
passiert ist jetzt wirklich eine punkt
angekommen wo es einfach nur dumm ist
einen marathon hat das geld wird die
läuft marathon in high heels
warum wisst ihr das ist genau das
problem an der menschheit das wäre
einfach so viele sachen einfach machen
wie wir sie machen können so ok ja da
kommt der ball einmal jemanden auf den
mond warum weil wäre doch lustig so hat
bisher noch keiner gemacht
ja ok aber das ist doch gut das ist noch
wissenschaftler gepasst aber wirklich
einen marathon in high heels laufen die
ja ich will dich so schmerzen leute die
an diese leute wirklich blaues für die
längste zunge der welt war super aber
nein danke das war's mal von diesem
wieder leute wie gesagt keine sex
vermeiden schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare wie es fanden hier drüben ein
vorgestelltes video auf dem ein knall
abonnieren ich will an der stelle raus
leute ich größere augen macht's gut